[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ce soir il faut être
très gentil avec notre nounours il a
très mal à la gorge
il a pris froid sur notre nuage et il ne
peut presque pas parlé oui je te sois au
1 tout petit moment au haut rose hanovre
saint-germain autant at the liégeois
s'est assuré milhas qu'il a tricoté à
qu'est ce que tu as tu as perdu ta
langue n'est pas fâché ou alors tu nous
en plus tu nous aimes je goûtais pauvre
gros nounours bon faut le dire mais
beaucoup de sacs à main ont soigné et la
hausse que toi pauvre petit mot love
tient un bon gars ici tu puis à pain
avec du miel moi comment tu fais haha
[Musique]
koulbout mais faut pas valu que nous
faut cracher
on n'a pas trop le petit portant daris
tu le feras surtout nuages et de mer qui
sera guérie non soin de toi bien
[Musique]
alors mon cher nounours je repos car
charisme pas trop rom soir nicolas et
pimprenelle sont vraiment très gentils
pour les remercier je vais leur chanter
une belle chanson
[Musique]
lorsque nounours ah vient tout est un et
qu'enfin il rejoint lorsqu'il remonte
de sa grande échelle que
nous partons dans le ciel
lorsque notre nuageux
un panel et nicolas
ce tour de chant
de leur côté sur leur petit oreiller
et je
j'ai hâte au lait
enfin
que la lune fait
aimer
omer
en main
il y en a qui suce leur doigt d'autres
qui ment
de leurs draps
la lune riz en l'air
elle aime bien les enfants
je me
de quels maux conseil l honneur
guérissent alors
à l'heure dite
on se crée touba
vraiment je ne
c'est ma
mais moi je sais qu'à tous les me dire
je niveau
oh
[Musique]
année
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]